a facebook whistleblower is exposing the
social media giant for what it really is
a money machine that places profit ahead
of public safety in an interview with 60
minutes francis hogan went on the record
to accuse the company of lying about its
efforts to remove hate and
misinformation from the platform instead
she says they've capitalized on it
and one of the consequences of how
facebook is picking out that content
today
is it is optimizing for content that
gets engagement or reaction but its own
research is showing that content that is
hateful that is divisive that is
polarizing
it's easier to inspire people to anger
than it is to other emotions facebook
has realized that
if they change the algorithm to be safer
people will spend less time on the site
they'll click on less ads they'll make
less money facebook makes more money
when you consume more content
people enjoy engaging with things that
elicit an emotional reaction
and the more anger that they get exposed
to the more they interact and more they
consume
senator cynthia lummus of wyoming joins
me now senator thank you for taking the
time to join me tonight i'm concerned
obviously about what's going on with
facebook and their control of the
information that that people get and i'm
concerned that this latest whistleblower
is just going to lead to more behavior
on the part of facebook to silence
people who they would like to silence
and those tend to be people who have
beliefs that are a lot more like yours
and mine than the beliefs of the people
in silicon valley who run the place
well sunshine disinfects and so the fact
that this whistleblower came forward
to document and expose information about
facebook's
unwillingness
to put safety especially for young
people ahead of profits
gives us a
reason to have a hearing tomorrow
in the commerce committee that will
include the whistleblower
and so we can begin to explore how to
protect people's privacy especially
young people who are experiencing damage
we know that 13 percent and more than 13
percent of young girls who use instagram
have increased feelings of suicide
as they gather data and then market to
those girls
who are insecure to begin with
the information that is being fed the
emotions that are being charged
are increasing their profits but also
really damaging young people in this
country the same thing is true with
regard to violence overseas we can point
to myanmar as an example
of uh
violence that occurred as a result of
some of the rage and
extended stays on facebook
that brought about violence there and
elsewhere and it is encouraging rage
even in europe some of the political
parties there
have complained to facebook
that by cultivating rage in order to get
people to stay online longer and spend
more money
they're also making
political
violence and political positions more
extreme
you know i certainly think that it's
high time that we woke up to the threat
that facebook offers i there's another
threat that you brought up recently in a
hearing regarding this step by the irs
to crack down and look into
the transactions that americans are
making even at the level of six hundred
dollars can you tell me a little bit
about why that concerns you
if the irs is using banks and credit
unions to gather information for
transactions over six hundred dollars
that ropes in every single american's
bank accounts
and that is invasive
government is
in invading our privacy more and more so
you've got big government invading our
privacy by way of the irs you've got big
corporations invading our privacy uh
with a market incentive and profit
incentive to do so and there is a role
for congress here to stop this kind of
invasive data collection
that can be used against the american
people and can be detrimental to their
well-being certainly could easily be
weaponized i think in a lot of
uncomfortable ways thank you senator for
joining me tonight hi i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now